o som
já pararam pra perceber que os tambores
causa na gente é impressionante né
pode ser um grupo de amigos de uma nação
de maracatu tambores hindus japoneses de
beleza africanos é o fato é que quando a
gente escuta essa batida logo nossa
atenção é chamada por alguma coisa fora
do comum que está acontecendo e desde os
primórdios na época das cavernas a gente
já usa os tambores para a percussão para
se comunicar
a gente pega um pedaço de pau lá e bati
na pagina numa pedra pra se comunicar ou
pra finalizar um possível predador ao
longo da uma da história da humanidade a
gente vê o tambor sendo utilizado na
música em rituais religiosos para ditar
o ritmo de exércitos ou nas milhares de
manifestações populares que a gente vê
mundo afora envolvendo tambor e esse
instrumento tem um uma capacidade
fantástica de mobilizar pessoas de
motivar e acima de tudo colocar um
grande grupo de pessoas numa mesma
pulsação isso é mágico
é por isso que a gente se arrepia quando
a gente se aproxima de uma bateria de
escola de samba por exemplo porque
aquela condenação entra na nossa
corrente sanguínea sanguínea e méxico as
novas moléculas e isso estimula o senso
de pertencimento gigantesco porque
quando a gente está num um grande grupo
no mesmo pulso a gente fica muito mais
forte um grupo junto a uma coisa um
grupo pensando junto é muito mais forte
ea gente tem a sensação de estar fazendo
parte de algo que é muito maior do que
nós mesmos
esse pulso também remete ao vento e da
nossa mãe quando a gente estava lá
dentro acolhido protegido bem alimentado
e já ouvindo tudo tudo daqui a pouco é o
coração do feto que se soma às batidas
do coração da mãe
e esse pulso nos mantém vivos desde os
primeiros minutos a nossa vida na minha
adolescência os nossos amigos qualquer
coisa era pretexto qualquer coisa era
motivo pra gente se reunir e fazer festa
fazer música não chegava com um violão
outro com uma gaita de boca com um bom
golo chocalho e lá estava gente fazendo
festa
você foi muito divertido mesmo que nem
todos sejam músicos todo mundo
participava daquela brincadeira no meio
desse dessa história toda
eu conheci um cara muito especial vários
né
mais um especial que o g meu parceiro
meu irmão
e assim como eu ele também um amante da
percussão da cultura popular ea gente
sempre teve bastante instrumento dentro
de casa a gente sempre teve bastante
repercussão e tambores
a gente começou a levar para esses
encontros todos os nossos instrumentos
não era só levar um chocalho um gol leva
tudo o que a gente queria distribuir as
pessoas para que elas também pudessem
participar daquela festa e muitos deles
falam mas eu não sou músico eu não sei
tocar interessa vai bater palma outros
chacoalhava aí
o importante é que todo mundo se
mobilizado e nisso surgiu a grande roda
de tambores uma festa onde o único
pretexto para a gente se divertir e
agente vivenciar isso aí junto e durante
algumas edições dessa festa a gente
percebeu duas coisas muito bacanas
um é que as pessoas se mobilizavam de
vários lugares e de várias maneiras para
fazer aquilo acontecer
outro é que o tambor tem essa capacidade
fantástica de mobilizar pessoas
o tambor é democrático as pessoas se
arriscam a participar se arriscam a
tocar
se eu chegar aqui com um monte de piano
de harpa de gaita de fole pois vocês não
tocava toca aí mas eu não sei tocar
agora está rolando uma batucada e aí o
carlinhos
contribuiu pra vocês daqui a pouco a
gente vai tocar junto rapidinho a gente
se arrisca participar o bate palma e faz
parte disso
só que a gente percebeu que nada
adiantava a gente reúne aquele grande
grupo de pessoas com muitos talentos
muitas capacidades em várias áreas de
atuação para simplesmente fazer festa
depois cada um botão seu tambor embaixo
do braço e para casa curtir seu corre a
gente podia analisar isso aí pra alguma
coisa que fosse melhor para a sociedade
e acima de tudo melhor para essas
pessoas também
depois de vários fatos de vários
acontecimentos não é que foram
despertando a consciência na gente
uma vez hoje ea gente foi no um asilo em
que queria se envolver com social
transformar a festa em algo social
a gente não sabia direito como a gente
nunca tinha se envolvido com isso o fato
é que a gente foi com uma sacola cheia
de instrumentos para dentro de um asilo
e quando a gente abriu a sacola é
começou a distribuir as pessoas lá teve
um efeito parecido com o que acontecia
na festa rapidamente daquelas senhoras
daquele lá estavam engajados e tocando e
é engraçado porque é contraditório você
chega a pagar vamos levar tambores para
o lar de repouso de idosos
o fato é que foi muito legal e quando a
gente saiu a gente se abraçou o cara tem
um caminho muito legal e e daquele
instante em diante a nossa vida tinha
mudado para sempre a gente não tinha nem
se dado conta do que ainda viria pela
frente
então a grande roda de tambores quero
uma festa passou a ser uma organização
não-governamental um propósito de
despertar a consciência das pessoas e
estimular que as pessoas compartilhem
seus talentos e seus dons naquilo que
ela sabe fazer de melhor
eu sei fazer uma coisa bem pra caramba
que você não sabe você sabe fazer outra
coisa bem pra caramba eu não sei
então a gente num justo as nossas
capacidades e se ajuda porque a gente
não se junta para levar isso para outras
pessoas que não tiveram acesso a essas
informações esses conteúdos
ao longo desse tempo todo desses 12 anos
várias coisas que foram muito bacanas
a gente acertou em algumas erro em
outras é normal processo de
experimentação
eu quero destacar a vocês dois projetos
em especial pra quebrar
é um projeto que acontece até hoje nas
moradias cajuru na em curitiba onde
começa são três etapas a gente começa
com os reciclados com as crianças onde
eles têm a oportunidade de pegar o ritmo
a gente passa por uma fase de construção
de tambor onde as próprias crianças
ajuda a ajudam a fazer seus tambores
isso dá um significado diferente para
eles né um outro envolvimento quando
eles pegam diferente de comprar um
tambor na loja entregar e novinho não as
crianças ajudaram a licht ajudaram a
pintar e depois termina com uma
apresentação para a comunidade
agora a gente quer levar este projeto
para dentro das escolas
no horário de contraturno e multiplicar
para outras crianças porque é um projeto
multidisciplinar quando a gente fala do
maracatu que tem lado de pernambuco a
gente pega o mapa e começa a falar de
geografia onde é que fica pernambuco
quando a gente fala da história dos
negros que vieram da áfrica
quando a gente fala do tempo a gente
está falando de matemática a gente fala
do trabalho em grupo
então é um processo disciplinar e o
projeto cirandeiro que até hoje à porta
de entrada de quem quer se envolver numa
grande roda projeto ciranda era um
projeto que leva atividades lúdicas e de
entretenimento para dentro de
associações e de instituições sociais
através dessas atividades
a gente quer estimular a reflexão dos
voluntários que vão junto com a gente
geralmente voluntário vai nesses lugares
e ele vai com o sentimento de pena eu
tenho minha vida tão linda e maravilhosa
vou lado a um pouco do meu tempo aquelas
criancinhas ou aqueles idosos que não
têm nada tadinho deles
só que esse sentimento de pena
automaticamente gera hierarquia e no
projeto ciranda gente inverte essa
lógica porque o foco do nosso projeto é
nos voluntários por mais que a gente
leve atividades artísticas e lúdicas
para as crianças e para os idosos que a
gente visita
o foco é nos voluntários que visitam
junto com a gente porque através dessa
ação ele abre espaço para a reflexão e
depois dessa reflexão ele torna uma nova
sanção seja uma grande roda em outras
outras assunto tem gente que vai se
envolver em outras instituições tem
gente que muda hábitos dentro da empresa
dentro de casa a gente não faz isso que
a gente quer angariar mais voluntários
para trabalhar na nossa instituição
a gente quer estimular que as pessoas
sejam voluntários do mundo para que eles
atuem naquilo que ele sabe fazer de
melhor no mundo como é o caso do alceu
alceu acompanhou esse processo com a
gente desde o início desde que a grande
roda era uma festa
ele começou a se envolver foi algumas
atividades dos cirandeiros com a gente e
de repente ele percebeu que ele poderia
usar uma das maiores paixões da vida
dele que é o futebol pra agir como um
agente de transformação social
ele fundou o instituto futebol de rua
que já trabalha há dez anos transforma a
vida de milhares de pessoas de crianças
através do esporte e do futebol de rua
da grandiosa não existe por causa da
grande roda existe por causa do alceu
existe por causa da equipe que trabalha
junto com o seu essa idéia já estava no
coração dele essa vontade de fazer
alguma coisa já estava no coração dele
desde sempre
a gente só foi lá e de um cãozinho para
mostrar que aquilo era possível dar um
choque um chacoalhão nas pessoas ea
gente acredita muito na idéia do do
individualismo coletivo você como
indivíduo
sabendo que você faz parte de algo maior
respeitar suas individualidades mas
saber que você é responsável pela
sociedade onde você vive pelo coletivo
ninguém fica tranqüilo por mais que sua
vida esteja tudo bem tudo legal se não
fica legal de saber que a sociedade não
está equilibrada
então quando você entende essa idéia do
individualismo coletivo isso muda e você
passa a atuar
realmente como um agente de
transformação e é por isso que a gente
usa os nossos tambores como uma
ferramenta para mobilizar as pessoas e
daí chacoalhão e é isso que a gente quer
fazer
6 por isso hoje por favor chega aí com
os batuqueiros vocês receberam os
instrumentos
a gente vai começar com uma brincadeira
que é o seguinte a gente fazer uma
brincadeira de pergunta e resposta
no verso eu vou chamar lá no mato em
areia e vocês vão responder areia em
arenas úma areia tem areia boa pra gente
peneira e no refrão no outro verso
refrão disco no verso a gente vai vocês
respondem foi um babado só mas eu
pensava que era um mas eu pensava que
era 2
mas eu pensava que era 3
mas eu pensava que era quadro boa agora
os seguintes e quem tá com um tubinho
amarelo e vermelho levanta aí e vocês
vão acompanhar a camila que na canal
faial
eles vão bater assim ó
agora no contra manter os outros grupos
nas outras cores mas seguir junto com o
giec ó pintar um chocalho só eu lá no
mato em areia tem areia no mar tem areia
boa pra gente pegar lá no mar e areia
que perdem a no mar é a dor pra gente
perder a mas eu pensava canal
mas eu pensava que era dor mas eu
pensava que era triste mas eu pensava
cara com a lágrima tem areia
leandro mar é amor a gente perder a ano
matéria era no mar é a boa a gente
perder a sua voz
lá no materno areia no mar tem a goa pra
gente peneira
a partir pra cima de um esquadrão
mas a galera daqui a pouco tem mais é o
seguinte às vezes vem uma galera chega
pra gente fala assim pô
que legal quando vocês são bonzinhos o
mundo precisava ter mais gente que nem
vocês não sei que a gente não faz isso
por que a gente é bonzinho
primeiro a gente faz isso que a gente
ama fazer isso a gente faz isso que nos
faz bem nos realiza consequentemente
ajuda outras pessoas também
só que a gente sabe que as nossas ações
geram impacto positivo para algumas
pessoas e atende a algumas demandas
sociais
só que o mundo tem várias outras
demandas por maior que seja os nossos
esforços a gente não consegue atingir
só quando a gente bate nosso tambor
a gente quer estimular mais e mais e
mais pessoas para que eles compartilhem
seus dons compartilhem seus talentos e
amplie esse poder de alcance amplia esse
poder desse impacto positivo que é
causado e é gerado por nós por isso que
a gente está aqui muito obrigado
o jogo